PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode,
we will talk about creating
serverless websites
on Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Imagine you're a
small company that
got really big, really quickly.
And now, you're seeing a lot of
traffic on your simple website.
But you don't want to deal
with the infrastructure
setup and maintenance when you
could be focusing on your core
business.
So let's walk through how not to
worry about the infrastructure
setup for your website
by deploying it
on managed serverless
platform like Cloud Run.
If you would like to deploy
on App Engine instead,
there is a link in the
description just for you.
Cloud Run is a managed compute
platform that automatically
scales stateless containers.
Stateless is important here,
since container instances
can be started or
stopped at any time.
These containers can be invoked
by web requests or Pub/Sub
events.
Cloud Run is also serverless.
It [INAUDIBLE] all the
infrastructure management
so you can focus on
what matters most--
building great applications.
So let's see how to build
a website with Cloud Run.
First, our setup logistics.
Identify or create a GCP project
that you would like to use.
Make sure that the
billing is enabled.
Enable the Cloud Run
and Cloud Build APIs.
If you don't have the
Google Cloud SDK installed,
today's your day.
Go ahead and get that.
OK.
Back to our example.
At the time of this recording,
Cloud Run is in beta,
so we are going to install the
beta components of the Google
Cloud SDK using gcloud
components install
beta command, and then we
will update the components.
This may take a few minutes.
To deploy, you can use any
web app of your choice.
For the purpose of
this demo, we will
create a hello world web
application in Python
and then deploy it
using Cloud Run.
Create a directory using mkdir
helloworld, and cd into it.
Then create a file named app.py
and paste this code into it.
This code creates
a basic web server
that listens on the ports
defined by port environment
variable.
Now we are ready to
containerize our app and upload
to container registry.
For that, we need to
create a new file called
Dockerfile in the same
directory as the source files.
Here, we define the
official Python image.
Copy the local code to
the container image.
Install production
dependencies and a command
to run the web service
on container startup.
Now we are ready to build
using Cloud Build by running
the build command from
the directory containing
the Dockerfile.
Gcloud build submit with
tag gcr.io slash project ID
slash service name.
I'm just calling it helloworld.
You will see success when
the build is successful.
To deploy the
container image, we now
need to run gcloud beta run
deploy image with the image
name, gcr.io slash
project ID slash
service name, platform managed.
When prompted to
select the region,
choose 1 for US central1.
Provide a service
name of your choice
and respond with
the yes to allow
unauthenticated invocations.
On success, we see
the service URL.
We can visit our
website by opening
that in our web browser.
Congratulations.
We have just deployed
a web application
packed in container
image on Cloud Run.
Cloud Run automatically
and horizontally scales
your container image to handle
the received request, then
scales back down when
the demand decreases.
You only pay for the CPU,
memory, and networking consumed
during request handling.
So today, we learned
a second recipe
for deploying a web
application on Google Cloud.
We created and deployed
a dynamic web application
on Cloud Run and learned that
if you host a website on Cloud
Run, you can rely on
Google Cloud for it
to scale with the demand.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
Here's hoping you can
whip up something great.
Join us next time, because we
will share the recipe to host
websites on compute engine.
If you liked this
video, then check out
the previous episodes, too.
And to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.